Speaker 1: Let's start with something a little
different today.
Over the last few weeks, I started getting
emails like this one that I'm putting up on
the screen saying, David, now that Joe Rogan
has been proven right about the vaccines,
now that Russell Brand and Kim Iverson have
been proven right about the vaccines and you
were wrong, are you going to apologize?
Are you going to issue a retraction or a traction
from Howard Stern fans to what you said?
Now, initially, I had no idea what these people
were talking about, but indeed, there are
a whole bunch of clips out there from people
like Jimmy Del Rey, a video called Joe Rogan
proven right about vaccines and myocarditis.
Russell Brand did a video Myocarditis and
Matt Hancock, The Great COVID Swindle.
A woman named Kim Iverson, who I guess only
does vaccine content.
Now, when I looked at her channel, it's like
just months of only vaccine stuff.
She did a video.
Why Florida Halts COVID MRSA for Men 18 to
39.
And then she also did a video in August called
Massive Study Proves Men Under 40 Have A Higher
Risk of Myocarditis.
Post-Vaccination So they are claiming that
they have been vindicated.
And some of my viewers are writing to me and
saying, David, all of these people have been
vindicated and you were wrong.
So let's see if we can talk this through.
The first question is what they believe is
vindication is they say they are right to
be skeptical and reluctant about the COVID
vaccine because of myocarditis and that that
has now been vindicated.
Now, the first part of this that's sort of
strange is that all of these videos came out
in early to mid-November and one in August
that I talked about.
And yet the study that they are all talking
about was published in April of this year.
That's almost eight months ago, huh?
That's sort of strange, right?
I mean, the study is published eight months
ago and they all talk about it within a few
days of each other in November.
Hmm.
That should at least raise a question so it
or should also make us wonder if all of these
videos were produced in November.
But they're talking about an April study.
Is there any other study data that came out
between April and November that they excluded
from their videos?
Well, we're going to figure that out.
But let's start with the study from April.
The big takeaway from the April study is that
men under the age of 40 have a higher risk
of myocarditis post-vaccination compared to
those who have not been vaccinated.
Now, the study actually says in it, quote,
Further long term studies will be needed to
estimate the incidence of pericarditis and
myocarditis in patients diagnosed with COVID.
This is critical.
It's not new information that there is a small
risk of pericarditis and myocarditis, particularly
to younger men from the many COVID vaccines.
We knew that it was a known risk, very rare,
but a known risk.
So that part isn't actually news.
But what these folks want to imply, and some
of them are straight up saying, is that the
risk of pericarditis and myocarditis from
COVID is lower than that from the vaccine.
In other words, the vaccine is more dangerous
than COVID.
The study they are citing specifically doesn't
say that.
It says you've got to study that in order
to figure out what is the incidence of pericarditis
and myocarditis in people who get COVID.
That's number one.
So what they are implying, the study doesn't
actually say.
Secondly, no one claimed the vaccine had no
risks.
Nobody claimed that.
We all talked about the side effects.
This specific risk was known and it was quantified
and it's really rare.
So pretending that learning that is newsworthy
also is dishonest.
Now, the more you delve into the data and
again, they're saying here's a study from
April, there are newer studies which we will
get to, but they want to focus on this study
from April.
The more you delve into the data, the less
stunning and shocking and surprising that
the data is.
An article from the American College of Cardiology
called Which COVID Vaccine You Get Can Impact
Myocarditis Risk.
Comments on the study and clarifies that quote,
Incidence of myocarditis is 2 to 3 fold higher
after the second dose of the Moderna vaccine
when compared to the Pfizer vaccine.
However, overall cases of heart inflammation
with either vaccine are very rare.
This is super important because, again, the
studies from April, we already knew this.
We already knew there's a slightly higher
risk of myocarditis from the vaccine.
It's slightly higher from the Moderna than
the Pfizer vaccine.
But the super important part is, you know,
how sometimes you hear these claims, health
claims, and I'm making this one up, this is
an imaginary health claim, but it will go
something like this.
Eating persimmon.
Doubles your risk of spontaneous blindness.
This is a joke.
Okay, we're making this up.
Eating persimmon doubles your risk of spontaneous
blindness.
And then you find out the risk of spontaneous
blindness in the general population is 0.01%.
And the people who ate persimmon went randomly
blind twice as frequently.
0.02% of the time.
Right.
Is that significant?
Is that something that you would alter your
behavior around, particularly if eating persimmon
had other health benefits?
That's an important analogy to what is being
talked about here.
Now, many doctors, including Guy Whit Burge,
who's an M.D. and an MPH, he's a cardiologist
at the Rabin Medical Center in Israel.
He said this information suggests that if
you have any kind of underlying cardiovascular
disease, get the Pfizer vaccine instead of
the medicine.
That's a doctor's take away from this study.
That's the takeaway.
Now to go further.
Many other studies don't even find that myocarditis
is more prevalent in those that take a vaccine
versus who don't take a vaccine.
So they're talking in November about an April
study.
There are newer studies that don't replicate
this result in August of 2022.
But this August rate, I mean, three months
ago, the American Heart Association published
a study reporting that, quote, the risk of
myocarditis is greater after a COVID infection
than after COVID vaccination and remains modest
after sequential doses of the booster.
However, the risk of myocarditis after vaccination
is higher in younger men, particularly after
a second dose of the Moderna vaccine information
we knew mostly.
And making it clear, it seems, that COVID
carries the higher risk.
That happens to come from a study which was
published in August of this year.
Now, that is a four month newer study than
the one Jimmy Doré and Russell Brand and
Kim Iverson are looking at.
Meaning they chose or didn't care or didn't
look to see.
Are there newer studies that conflict with
the one from April that we're all titillated
by?
But we have something kind of even more interesting
and it's even newer information.
An October study.
So this is last month from Penn State College
called, quote, myocarditis induced by COVID
infection is substantially greater than the
risk posed by vaccines.
This study found myocarditis in induced by
COVID infections is worse than that.
Myocarditis induced by the vaccines.
Okay, that's from last month.
And the other part of this is even if you
imagine that the risk of myocarditis is higher
from the vaccine than it is from COVID, or
rather that they are the same.
If you say, okay, well, myocarditis is is
more likely when you get a vaccine and it's
more likely when you get COVID.
Imagine that we grant both of those equally.
The myocarditis associated with the vaccine
is milder than the myocarditis associated
with COVID.
That's an important consideration.
Dr. Nicola Kleine, who's a vaccine expert
at Kaiser Permanente, says, quote, Vaccine
associated myocarditis is usually milder than
the viral type.
That's if the risk were equal.
And many studies say that's not the case.
Many studies find this and we're putting another
article up on the screen.
Here is how some of the commentators I just
mentioned reported on this.
Jimmy Doria, when talking about this, said,
Before we give forgiveness for the people
who were Nazis around COVID policy, who were
pro lockdown, pro mandates, and they were
100% wrong on all that stuff.
It's okay to be wrong about that stuff.
What's not okay is to then demonize people
who disagree with you on facts.
Well, what are the facts?
Choosing an eight month old study when there
are newer studies, multiple newer studies
that disagree on or no.
So that's what's going on.
There's no retraction needed.
There's no apology needed.
Most of this study comes out with information
that's not new.
The parts that are more notable have already
been contradicted by multiple, newer studies.
I have no horse in this race.
I want the truth and I want the healthiest
public health situation for everybody.
That's it.
So that is the information as I know it.
If you have additional information that I
should be considering or evaluating, by all
means, send it to me.
If you like these types of segments, make
sure to subscribe on YouTube.
On the page for this video.
Like if you're watching this video right now,
hit subscribe.
We see the analytics of which clips generate
subscribers and if this is of interest to
the audience, we will absolutely do more of
these.
We're going to take a quick break and be right
back.
Lest we forget, remember that the David Pakman
show is a community funded program.
We depend on the support of our viewers, our
listeners, podcast subscribers, people who
watch a clip on YouTube or listen to us on
the radio or even seeing the Tik Tok videos
where things are blowing up very quickly.
I'll say more about that probably on the bonus
show soon because it is interesting what's
happening on tick tock.
But my invitation to you is to get the extra
content, get the bonus show, get the commercial
free audio and video streams of the show simply
by signing up at join Packman dot com That's
all you have to do you go to join Pacman dot
com you can use the coupon code 24 starts
now because it does if you prefer you can
use the coupon code please no more Trump and
you have to say it like that at least in your
head when you type it in please no more trump
both coupon codes save you big time off of
the cost of a membership at join pacman dot
com.